[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Hi.
I'm Natalie Villalobos,
and here at Google, I
have the extreme honor of
working with incredible women
in the technology industry.
And today, I have Macy
Kuang visiting the "Coffee
with a Googler" stage.
Welcome, Macy.
MACY KUANG: Thank you.
Thanks for inviting me.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So I'm really
excited to talk to you today
about what you're working on.
Can you give our
audience a little peek
into some of the projects
that you have going on?
MACY KUANG: So I have done a lot
more things, majorly in games.
I'm the GDE for wearables,
so I have done a lot of apps
for Glass and for Wear.
Right now, I'm working on VR
games for Google Cardboard.
So the game concept is
you're in a dungeon,
and you try to find enemies
nearby you by the audio.
So they're kind of
invisible, but you
have to look around and
hide and seek and find them.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: How
do you get rid of them?
MACY KUANG: You have to
pretty much kill them.
That's very violent but--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Cool.
And I guess, stepping
back, how did you even
get into creating that project?
How did you get into
the technology industry?
MACY KUANG: I have been always
interested in technology.
I used the computer when
I was the age of three,
because my mom, she got her
hands on computer really
early on.
But then she kind of
stopped letting me use it
when I became a teenager
because where I grew up,
computer was considered
as a really bad thing.
But maybe that's
why it made me want
to use computer more because
it was forbidden and stuff.
So after I came
to North America,
I started to learn
how to use computers,
and I took a class
in programming.
It was really overwhelming.
I really loved it.
I have art background.
I can draw.
With the add-on of
programming skills,
actually, I can combine
good-looking things
and technology together,
make them become
some form of useful tools.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, something
beautiful, design and develop.
MACY KUANG: Exactly.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So that app that you
were talking about
for Cardboard,
can we get it in
the Play Store yet?
MACY KUANG: Not yet.
It's in beta testing.
Actually, I sent an open invite
to all my Google+ friends,
and we have around 20 people
in my beta testing group.
Once it's ready,
everyone can have it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Nice.
I'm excited for it.
Thank you.
So you mentioned an acronym.
You said GDE.
MACY KUANG: Yes.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
What does GDE stand for?
MACY KUANG: So GDE is the
Google Developer Expert program.
I'm honored to be nominated
by one of the local GDE
organizers.
I ran a couple of events related
to Google Glass at that time,
and I was being selected.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Super cool.
MACY KUANG: Thank you.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And so
what do you do as a GDE?
So you're doing these cool
projects with Cardboard.
I think you had also
mentioned earlier
that you do some workshops,
like some technology workshops,
so you're also a teacher.
MACY KUANG: Yes.
I really like
technology and I would
like to share my experiences.
And also, if I can, I would
like to educate as many people
as I can.
As a GDE, we don't really
have a restricted curriculum.
It was more like an
endorsement from Google.
However, I think
being a Wearable,
GDE is really, really
exciting because our group
is very small.
So we actually are able to
have Google Hangout every month
with the Google X team.
So, for example, we speak with
Timothy Jordan pretty much
every month, and we
are always ready when
something new is coming up.
So it's kind of
fulfilling my eager,
and also just it's really
good to know the people who
are working behind them.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
That's really cool access.
So you and I met a
couple years ago.
MACY KUANG: Right.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I think
probably over a Google Hangout.
And at the time, we
were talking about how
we can increase the visibility
of women in technology,
especially-- there's
so many women out there
that I think want to
be in the industry
and are also already
in the industry.
And so you created
a YouTube show.
I mean, it's a channel, but
you have a regular show.
Can you tell us more about that?
MACY KUANG: So thank you
a lot for inviting me
to that program.
I had an idea of running a
YouTube channel for the longest
time, but no one
really encouraged
me to go forward with it.
So at that time, I think it
was you emailed me saying,
we are doing a program
to encourage women have
more visibility on YouTube.
I was like, wow, that's
exactly what I wanted to do.
And since we have a
community of other women
who are making similar content,
I feel like I'm not alone.
I'm not the only one
who is fighting for it.
And I created my first video.
I got so much support
from the community.
At first, it was just
women, and eventually
everyone, guys, girls, all over
the world watching my videos.
Just during I/O, there
were people from Brazil
that came to me because
they're students
watching my video somehow.
I'm very proud of
what I have done.
And really, thanks for
the Women Techmakers.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So tell
us, what is your show called?
Because I know that the
audience is really stoked.
I'm sure they want to watch it.
MACY KUANG: Yes.
So my show is called
"Code to Create."
So coding to create things.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
And I guess it's like that
blend, again, of your art
background with your
development background.
MACY KUANG: Yes.
So I'm trying to cover things
that's difficult for me.
My goal is try to create
a video Stack Overflow.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Nice idea.
MACY KUANG: Things that's
really hard, but hard
to explain in a text format.
So I try to bring them
into a video format that
is easier for people to
consume and understand,
especially for developers.
We have so many buttons
and things that you click.
It's very hard to explain
over just images and text.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And so you're
a Google Developer Expert.
You're creating really awesome
applications for Cardboard,
for Wearables.
It's awesome.
Tell me, what do you
think is the future
of wearable technology?
MACY KUANG: Actually, I think
it can end up in a lot of ways.
It's really hard to
predict, but I think
there are two major trends.
One is all the wearables
become less visible.
So you would just
look really normal,
and Glass is to look just
like regular glasses.
Clothes just look
like regular clothes
but with some chips in it.
I think another trend
is people are just
going to get used to it.
Like they know you're
wearing something,
but everybody's
wearing, it and they
will accept it like everybody
carries their phone around.
I think that's just
something people are possibly
going to get used to it.
So I think the final decision
has to be made by everybody.
It's not just the people
who are creating the tech,
but also the people
who are using them.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much for
spending so much time here.
Thank you so much for coming
to I/O. You are an industry
leader, and I'm so thankful
you joined us on the show.
MACY KUANG: Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Thank you so much.
Thanks.